[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi est ce que les marmailles avec
les parents il doit n'y avoir nous tout
simplement parce que les enfants
nous ça raconte les histoires que zot y
dessine satisfait des dessins et nous
nous fait les personnages des dessins
voilà les et des personnages les lieux
les décors etc et donc nous et on part
de ça pour créer une histoire complète
de 45 minutes sur
sur bar on sépare encore est ce qui est
important c'est que chaque spectacle
serait unique puisque c'est une
improvisation
c'est ce moment la faute là à ce moment
là pouvoir tel spectacle
en fait c'est ses hôtes imaginaire azote
que nous retranscrit en fait c'est ça et
ce qui est génial c'est que les enfants
un imaginaire qui est bien plus grand
que nous les adultes avec toute notre
classe dans laquelle on se met et moins
les marmailles banques font des trucs de
fou et nous ça nous amène dans des zones
monde mais qui sont totalement différent
de ce qu'on fait d'habitude
et là ça va mais on sait nous surprend
et c'est magnifique ce qu'ils arrivent à
faire les gamins si ce type peut voir
par exemple je prends moi l'histoire du
prince banane dans le lac des cygnes
voilà et basso qui vient voir nous et
surtout les parents amènent hautement my
vient voir à nous
k
cl
winkel